okay well I could talk let me talk about
the situation at the Ivy League
universities first the question broadly
speaking covers the question about
intelligence and about its diverse
manifestations and about its role in
selection for university to go back and
look at the records at Harvard for
example in the early 1960s the typical
idea for a Harvard student was about 105
to 110 not much above average but that's
because they were finishing schools for
they for the rich roughly speaking and
you know you're if you had a rich father
and he made his money he was probably
well above average and intelligence but
if you're his offspring there's
regression towards the mean so there's
no reason to assume that by nature of
your position you were going to be
particularly intelligent anyways the
average Ivy League student wasn't was
great but not outstandingly so now it's
like 100 IQ 145 3 standard deviations
above the mean because the reason for
that is because they're selected by the
SAT scholastic aptitude test
it's an IQ test they won't say it's an
IQ test but that doesn't matter
it isn't test it's an IQ test as simple
as that any any test that contains a
sufficiently diverse range of
problem-solving questions that's rank
ordered in accuracy among people is an
IQ test the correlations like point 85
so and what has happened there's two
things that have happened I mean the Ivy
League's have got more and more
selective because they can and so the
average IQ of their students has just
continued to move upwards and then the
average IQ of the population is actually
increased to a substantive degree - over
the last 50 years partly because partly
perhaps mostly because of improved
nutrition and and information exposure
alone among the like the more deprived
members of the culture better to watch
TV than to sit alone in your crib for
example and isolated and people have
enough food now so the really low end of
the intelligence spectrum is being
truncated and the general population IQ
is increased so with regards to
institutions like the University of
Toronto say the average IQ at the
University of Rome
was somewhere between 120 130 and we
know that because we tested it and it's
not surprising because you're basically
selected for cognitive prowess right
because grades are a rough marker of
intelligence conscientiousness by the
way also matters independent trait
because the best two predictors of
university grades are conscientiousness
and intelligence not creativity by the
way zero correlation with creativity